[Applaudissements]
il y a Solen Royal qui est avec nous
pour Solen explique applaudissement
[Applaudissements]
merci bonsoir c'est Go merci d'être
làci bonsoir alors c'est Golen qui va
nous parler aujourd'hui toujours dans
l'actualité toujours dans l'actualité je
rappelle que cette petite séquence
sérieuse pour objectif ce que j'essaie
de faire d'expliquer en des termes
simples des choses
dont on a entendu parler dans
l'actualité bon et à partir du du drame
terrible d'ailleurs on a une pensée pour
les les victimes de tous ceux qui sont
attaqués et assassinés par des fichiers
s on a entendu beaucoup de choses un peu
tout et n'importe quoi parfois genre il
faut mettre tous les fichiers s en
prison ou genre tous les terroristes
sont des malades mentaux donc que que
disent exactement les textes moi je suis
pas là pour polémiquer mais je vousis
expliquer exactement ce qui est comment
c'est organisé ce que signifie un
fichier qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
fichiers et qu'est-ce que fait la
psychiatrie par rapport à ce type de
problème alors qu-ce d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'un fichier bah un fichier
c'est juste une liste c'est une liste
c'est une liste de nom ah ouais quand
même donc un fichier s se trouve sur
cette liste d'une fiche qui s'appelle s
pourquoi s sécurité sécurité et même
sûreté de l'État et donc dans ce vaste
fichier qui qui est plus vaste qui
s'appelle le fichier des des personnes
recherchées j'en reparlerai tout à
l'heure parce qu'autrefois il a évolué
c'est est-ce que vous pouvez fermer
votre gueule en en en coulisse c'est un
truc de ouf on dirait qu'il y a un mec
qui fait une prière mon frère
excusez-moi c'est Go donc dans ce
fichier il y a d'autres listes par
exemple il a pas il y a pas que les
fichiers il y a pas que les fichiers s
il y a par exemple les fichiers j ça
veut dire recherché par la justice les
fichiers PJ recherché par la police les
fichiers m c'est le fichier des mineurs
en fugue le fichier V le fichier les
évadés le fichier it interdit de
territoire ou le fichier les Qts ceux
qui sont obligés de quitter le
territoire français il y a aussi les
fichiers eu les ex bonjour François
Holland
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi on a le droit de se détendre
c'est pas mal pas mal elle est mal mal
c'est pas mal mais
surtout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
depuis l'attentat du Bataclan il y a un
nouveau fichier qui est le fichier des
radicalisés à caractère terroriste alors
il a un sigle un peu complexe c'est le
fsprt c'est-à-dire le fichier des
signalements pour la prévention et la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
donc c'est ce fichier qui est concerné
donc vous voyez quand on parle des
fichiers du fichier s en fait c'est par
facilité de langage parce que celui-ci
est un peu plus complexe et dans le
fichier s ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez
c'est que il y a pas seulement des
radicalisés ou des gens dangereux pour
la sécurité mais il y a aussi euh il y a
aussi des des des militants contre les
autoroutes il y a aussi des militants
contre la destruction des forêts il y a
un peu de tout pourquoi parce que dans
le fichier s il y'y a pas d'obligation
de suivi donc c'est bien ce fichier là
dont je viens de vous parler à caractère
de de radicalisé à caractère terroriste
qui est le plus important pourquoi parce
que contrairement au fichier s il
autorise le suivi c'est-à-dire on peut
la police a le droit de regarder ce que
font les gens de les mettre sur écoute
et cetera donc d'assurer le suivi ce qui
n'est pas le cas du fichier s euh et
dans ce fichier déradicalisé ils sont
classés par catégories six catégories du
plus dangereux au moins dangereux donc
vous voyez c'est ce fichier là qui est
très important et donc effectivement si
quelqu'un a été inscrit à tort
uniquement dans le fichier s et pas dans
celui-ci il a pas été suivi alors c'est
pas toujours facile hein il a pas été
suivi et surtout contrairement au
fichier s et surtout il a pas pu être
contrôlé ni pisté en fait dans ce
fichier combien il y a de personnes il
il y a 20000 personnes dans ce fichier
déradicalisé dont 5100 sont en lien avec
le djihadisme c'est-à-dire ont été
repéré qu ayant des liens soit par leurs
réseaux sociaux la les liens qu'ils ont
les échanges téléphoniques et cetera
donc c'est ces 5100 personnes qui
aujourd'hui sont très dangereuses en
France et dont 1411 personnes en
situation irrégulière donc la première
décision ce serait déjà d'expulser ces
1400 personnes et de contrôler le suivi
peut-être c'est ça le débat aujourd'hui
politique c'est pas peine de polémiquer
mais c'est vraiment comment est-ce qu'on
contrôle beaucoup plus étroitement ces
différentes personnes voilà juste pour
l'histoire autrefois ce fichier des des
personnes recherchées était considérable
parce qu'il y avait 650000 personnes
c'était la le temps des renseignements
généraux où tout le monde était fiché
c'est tous les opposants politiques tous
les les les syndicalistes tous les
militants associatifs tout le monde
était dessus François mteran a été sur
le a été fiché et C on on était tous
fichés et donc il a de l'ordre qui a été
remis dans ces atteintes à la liberté
pour se reconcentrer sur les différentes
listes que je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure alors ensuite euh qui sont je je
j'ajoute que ceux qui sont sur le
fichier s voyez que c'est pas le plus
important c'est que au bout de 2 ans
s'il y a pas eu de délit leur nom
disparaît de ce fichier ça donc vous
voyez comme l'actualité parle du fichier
s mais c'est l'autre c'est le fichier
des radicalisés terroristes qui est le
plus important
deuxème grande question on a entendu
aussi dire finalement les terroristes
sont des malades mentaux mais non si on
dit ça ça veut dire qu'on rentre dans
dans la logique de l'excuse et donc il y
a eu d'ailleurs un communiqué des des
médecins psychiatre qui a été publié
hier qui redit bien aussi clairement les
choses qui est responsable de quoi dans
une société et comment on estit en
contrôle les gens dangereux et de quelle
façon car selon les études dans les
radicalisé il y a entre 5 et 8 % de
personnes qui présentent des troubles
psychiatriques pas plus d'accord voyez
même dans le le cas horrible là du du du
procès auquel on assiste avec Fourniret
on dit pas qu'il est fou et pourtant ce
qu'il a accompli est absolument horrible
et donc souvent comme on ne comprend pas
encore le terrorisme et qu'on ne sait
pas l'anticiper on dit bah ils sont fous
comme si c'était une excuse mais non ça
se retourne même parce que du coup on
les déresponsabilise
donc et deuxièmement on a entendu dire
mais finalement il y a une faille il
faudrait administrer il faudrait pouvoir
hospitaliser de force les gens mais cela
existe toute personne agressive
peut-être hospitalisée de force soit par
un arrêté du préfet soit par un arrêté
du mer c'est-à-dire sans perdre le temps
de passer devant un médecin ou devant la
justice et donc
l'hospitalisation de force est
absolument autorisé aujourd'hui dans les
textes ça s'appelle l'hospitalisation
sous contrainte pour toute personne
agressive et violente donc quelles sont
les causes ensuite au bout la la durée
maximale de cette hospitalisation c'est
12 jours au bout de 12 jours la personne
qui a été hospitalisée de force dans un
hôpital psychiatrique à va être entendu
par un juge le juge va voir en en
fonction aussi du du certificat médical
si cette hospitalisation doit être
prolongée ou si au contraire l'individu
parce qu'il y aura une plainte contre
lui va va passer devant la justice et va
avoir un autre un autre protocole
judiciaire peut-être terminé en prison
si effectivement les plaintes qui sont
portées contre lui donnent lieu à cette
condamnation alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut pas dire que les tous les
terroristes sont des sont des malades
mentaux je l'ai dit à l'instant parce
que sinon ça veut dire qu'ils sont pas
responsables et puis sinon ça fait ça
fait oublier les raisons pour lesquelles
les terroristes passent à l'acte
pourquoi est-ce qu'il passe à l'acte
terroriste par idéologie euh djihadiste
ou par ambrigadement c'estàd compr pas
ce qui se passe mais ils ont été
embriganés par un leader djihadiste ou
parce qu'il présente des pathologies
mentales mais ça on a vu que c'était
quand même très très marginal donc
rendre responsabl les psychiatres voyez
du du terrorisme c'est c'est pas non
seulement c'est pas juste mais en plus
c'est
pas c'est dangereux parce que ça empêche
d'agir sur les vraies causes du
terrorisme et l'amalgame entre
terrorisme et maladie mentale détourne
en fait des vraies solutions donc pour
terminer et comme l'ont dit les
psychiatres dans leur dans leur
communiqué le passage à l'acte des
individus dangereux parce que c'est de
ça don qu'il s'agit c'est le passage à
l'acte des individus dangereux B les
psychiatres ils sont confrontés
absolument tous les jours mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui sur quoi il
faudrait qu'on travaille collectivement
c'est que par rapport à ce qu'il avait
avant il y a de nouvelles formes de
radicalisation il y a des violences de
masse qui nécessitent de nouveaux
raisonnements et de nouvelles façons de
d'agir c'est-à-dire faire un travail de
fond pluridisciplinaire pour trouver des
solutions et un suivi plus plus resserré
sur les 5000 individus qu'on a identifié
tout à l'heure sans systématiquement les
les mettre en psychiatrie mais au
contraire régler le problème de de la
violence et enfin une fois de plus je
pense que ce qu'il faut absolument dire
aussi c'est que il y a il y a une telle
pénurie de médecin un tel manque de
moyen dans la PS piatrie c'est tellement
criant aujourd'hui qu'on peut même
parler de situation d'abandon et
d'extrême précarité de
l'hôpital des hôpitaux psychiatriques et
du faible nom de médecins tellement ils
sont peu reconnus et je pense qu'on
pourrait d'ailleurs leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui et donc il y a vraiment une
urgence aujourd'hui voyez indépendamment
de de la surveillance de la de la
répression ou de l'expulsion des 100 qui
ont été identifiés et du renforcement du
suivi des autres c'est vraiment remettre
à niveau la psychiatrie car ce qu'on
observe aussi c'est que et c'est sur un
autre sujet qui a fait l'actualité on y
reviendra peut-être dans les violence
conjugal et dans les féminicides s'il y
avait plus de lit d'hospitalisation en
psychiatrie et bien systématiquement on
pourrait commencer par mettre les maris
violents qui vont devenir meurtriers
parce qu'on les laisse chez eux parce
qu'il y a pas de solution et qu'on peut
pas les incarcérer tout de suite c'est
de les mettre tout de suite en
hospitalisation forcée dans un hôpital
psychiatrique donc de la remise à niveau
de la des hôpitauxpsychiatriques dépend
beaucoup beaucoup de la lutte contre les
violences que subissent aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop de victime encore euh Marc
Antoine
merci du coup il peut plus plaisanter là
ça y est merci c'est Goolen en tout cas
vous avez peut-être une question non non
mais c'est bon merci Mar aucune bah
après ça non c'est bon ce me je va
déconner c'est bon sa blague était sympa
franchement moi j'ador la Blue vous
voulez que j'ai mis Nicolas Sarkozi mais
quelle indignité Nicolas Sarkozi devant
ses golain
royale j'ai l'impression quand je vous
regarde j'ai l'impression de me voir
monsieuroun vous êtes toujours là avec
vos bras en train de faire des
gesticuler comme ça vous
voyez il est bon franchement casse-toi
hein il faut aller
voir'estce vous avez vu vous avez vu
bravo royale
merci et oui exactement merci merci
merci cheè merci beaucoup